hey guys it's Justine and today we're
talking about one of my favorite
features in the new iPad OS update that
will be coming out later this year
it's called scribble it's basically
handwriting recognition for your iPad at
WWDC 2020 they announced some new
updates to iOS 14 of course the new iPad
OS update which I'm running a beta
version of currently if you do have
access to a developer account it is
recommended that you don't install beta
software on your main devices because
they are beta they are still in
development there are bugs and there are
things that they aren't working out
because it is in beta and it's not for
mass consumption but I do have a
developer account and I'm installing the
iPad OS on one of my old iPads with of
course the new iPad pro keyboard not the
magic keyboard but in this video I
wanted to show you my favorite feature
that they announced I thought this was
something that they would have had a
long time ago but they are just
currently releasing this and it's pretty
cool let's check it out let's go into
the Notes app and I'm gonna write you a
note dear YouTube I love you so now I'm
able to take this text and I'm able to
treat it as if it were just regular text
it gives you these little anchor points
and I wanted to copy this text I would
just do the same action that I normally
would do so let's just press on it like
we're gonna copy it and you have the
option to copy as text so we're gonna go
to pages and I can take this handwritten
text and paste it into Pages dere
YouTube aisle or you okay so that could
be like a maybe a handwriting issue that
does look like an R okay you're right
let's try it again now I'm gonna try to
rewrite love look at that so let's copy
that as text and see if my better
handwriting helped it did those are cool
because you can use this and you can
change the colors of anything that
you've already written I love it because
it's just treating this like a piece of
text which it is but it's handwritten
text handwriting recognition will also
work in the search bar so if I want to
search for let's see Twitter that is
terrible handwriting okay it found
Twitter that's cool oh my gosh this is
my sister's baby
I am oh my goodness I am writing this on
iPad OS so I just wrote that in Twitter
like in the Twitter app the other cool
thing is scratching out something that
is wrong so I'm gonna just scratch out
the M delete
hello I'm writing I by two eyes
handwriting recognition it's a pretty
cool hi this is gonna be so fun I don't
like to write but now that I know that I
can
I might start writing again oh look at
this choose an option smart annotation
drawing I'm gonna do drawing I can add a
drawing here in two pages this is not
new but I still think it's pretty cool
that my drawing right here Justine was
here I really I used to always tag stuff
like in school I really just seen was
here when I was a child that's probably
not good so going back to drawing and
notes this is cool too because you can
just do a long hold and it will
automatically make the lines super clean
and neat so if I want to draw a triangle
circle everything is so perfect and neat
I love this it also treat these as
images it will also separate images and
text so it'll be able to determine if
you're drawing something or if you're
drawing something that is supposed to be
text so that's pretty awesome I cannot
wait for all of the new updates I can't
believe it's almost iPhone season
already look where cuz this year gone I
have no idea well this is one of my
favorite features to scribble on the new
iPad OS that should be out later this
year I would love to know from you guys
though what is your favorite feature
that was announced either in iOS 14 or
an iPad OS there's someone you new fun
things coming that I just cannot wait
for all of them to be released I'll go
to link in the description if you want
to subscribe to our podcast my sister
and I just recently started one and we
did a special bonus episode talking
about WWDC and some of the things that
were our highlights be sure to subscribe
and hit the bells you'll be notified
when I post a new video I will
definitely be posting some more
and I will see you guys very very soon
when I post in your videos but with that
I'm gonna go edit and I will see you
guys
[Music]